okay back in like a sorry I think the
microphone is all [ __ ] up [ __ ] is this
why is that it's a plate with a circular
dial okay you me check that they burn
anything in here ok so I'm going back to
the other room and we all know what's
gonna happen when I get on the other
room that's jumpscare it's gotta be ones
very fresh for one very fresh or one
ready any I guess that goes and looking
none that's strange anyway here's the
plate um it's all match up right come on
and we go ok ok ok good god it looks
like we got a duck coming up not great
we had a bunch of [ __ ] here and I felt
such as is for the new weather device
tamar gonna buy some pays mom's birthday
have night where guys last night five
years ago it's dark tall man sending
over her okay anything else in here
maybe the combination is this thing
well he went in here he opened it oh
it's so swollen enough um downstairs oh
great we're gonna get [ __ ] murdered
we're gonna get murdered I mean what are
we gonna tell we're gonna get murdered
here comes to jump scare here comes the
jokes care all right what do we do Ron
okay poor job ok this way trying to get
murdered and heels in here okay
shut as I can mr. murder I guess that
was a really shitty spot to hide that
that is very good shut ready here cuz
I'm hiding in the chest as time [ __ ]
I'm hiding in the chest this time what
the [ __ ] this is my spot I'm gonna get
[ __ ] murder
it's Betsy's me already right yeah how's
any other room guess I can't hide in
there again and I guess I got to go to
the other room after I hit on saving
[Music]
sorry hide under the bed can I hat under
bed
okay okay maybe hide in this room I
can't jump out the window get a
success
you
[Music]
[Music]
okay I just [ __ ] think for a sec
[Music]
and and the fireplace
[Music]
[ __ ]
you
hmm I mean this chain
[ __ ] it I'll show the other one down oh
there's all that better Chuck goes it
open
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this hello Bernie a lot of
pats at a lot of pattern but there's
only one way I got [ __ ] there's only
one way to go
dad has gone that way but i guess not
what's that Tim what is that that's [ __ ]
happen there what is that ah iraq's what
is that
ah right ja sock and great
[ __ ] sucking loss of them right I
passed out right now and I guess gonna
be a scary thing she has to wake up is
not that
now shut there's a stretch hello sir I
Anna castaway I God God God
says late what the [ __ ] is going on here
[Music]
bottles once we play some heavy asa
lightest
[Music]
[Music]
the door is stuck
[Music]
very strange I'll bet toast Ryan Jeff
very well I bet toe strange don't you I
cry
[Music]
[ __ ] ya eres around the paper to
know that you got a special award and I
get get Cynthia Marguerite Higgins is my
hero she want to pull it I got she goes
to war zones marches with the troops
nothing scares her and she gets the
story Marguerite Higgins doesn't run
from a juicy story just because her life
is in danger I got neither will i [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is gonna get a cow oh I know
I am someone playing on the piano it's
[ __ ] are fine
mommy's a piece of [ __ ] hey dad took me
to Wichita once before he died we drove
for four hours to get there Slade he's
just got penis sucker I hate to say it
but she's a penis sorry went home you
never explained just told me to get in
the car I guess he knew he was going to
die he's a penis sucker you know what
happens to penis suckers they get penis
stuff good jazz get dad got good
let me clean that for you Star Circle
Square let's say let's say something
right there fux under here
oh here we go start suckle square Matt
okay Bell thank you i love you concern
the symbol is very search that's a safe
combination how'd i get back up there
without getting murdered that's the real
question that is the real question
what's out here what's out here
this guy's devil is really able anything
out here is it here well we got to get
going already hey ready what is this
using the moon la
alright lets up when i get murdered okay
there's a strange warring in here
hmm StarClan
the [ __ ] is that noise
ready
up
you
yeah that he has my chest a guy goes
hmm and they out there
i won the bottles minute that can't I
can't so is there can a printer here
that's right i got another bottle
[Music]
but the [ __ ]
[Music]
lots of [ __ ] here if woodcutter killed
Bullard he was pretty sneaky about it no
marks on the body no sign of a struggle
coroner ruled it was pancreatic failure
how do you kill a man without leaving a
mark on him and why return to the scene
of the crime all questions to be
answered until time right am i right
[ __ ] okay
ok then I'll be back then I'll be back
hey what's over here is this a study
is this the door at the knob there's
some drawer that he did not
okay here we go here we go where is an
update asst three bottles now gotta keep
going today 25 the last bottle
I hear [ __ ] move it oh [ __ ] when a
[ __ ] mass is gone yes a nine it yeah
sat on it
she got some nice tats us all I gotta
say all right
what is this dear Harris
need money CNT needs money
[ __ ] says they got five days
sucks am
hey I got this I got this I got this I
got this that what is over here and is
this holy [ __ ] no way Jose am I going
down there you gotta be [ __ ] crazy it
need to be [ __ ] batshit crazy me
think that's gonna happen oh my god i
was locked myself to sleep i guess i
gotta go back upstairs get up up up ah
Jesus Bobby's son Oh like you're not
gonna be a writer body it just not
anything over here
we do everything I can take out that
letter
no cuz i go back upstairs ah shut shut
think it was in here [ __ ] a I'm I hear
nobody knows here's the mirror to what
happens now oh [ __ ] the monkeys here
[Music]
[ __ ] scary okay well we gotta can't
move my match oh great
[Music]
[Music]
ok 10 it left at 20 all right 50 and
that's that yeah
okay Zach at the HS
there's a secret room got in the freezer
[ __ ] ok
she said this is getting [ __ ] a rail
now okay good
[Music]
it's too [ __ ] dark in here
[Music]
shet this is horrifying
[Music]
the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] now that was [ __ ] scary Olly
shut that [ __ ] was watching me
[Music]
[Music]
that's the [ __ ] that is I think about
his dad
why is it so quiet [ __ ] scary
I guess I gotta get out of here [ __ ]
scary so if I get killed walk in scary
little fall through the [ __ ] floor
boards what does it make me stop right
here saw something here [ __ ] here it
goes here it goes and I like this game
oh [ __ ] ready oh oh [ __ ] yeah goes oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay well I'm gonna end
this right here save it thanks for
watching guys join me the next episode
thank ya